we had a lot of narcs back then because
i remember a lot of dudes would get sent
back to our school and they'd be narcs
you know yeah and uh we had a few of
those the jrotc kids did y'all yeah they
they would like dress up like cops on
like friday nights at football games and
they just pretty much just tell you to
throw the trash away yeah yeah i don't
know what they're doing now but and they
would have wooden guns sometimes and
after school there was always this group
of kids running around the halls with
like wooden guns yeah and there was
jarrod it was like flipping around and
[ __ ] it was rotty yeah yeah and they'd
always be like have like these kind of
like semi
kind of like
marine haircuts yeah even though they
didn't have to get them i think they
just got them anyway you're gonna do it
and then they get themselves cauliflower
here a little bit just themselves
the wooden gun's weird because you're
like what are you gonna do to somebody
give him a splinter in the forehead to
[ __ ] freeze
some of these dudes were savages and
they would all do that car speed thing
where they would race their cars and put
the quarter mile on the window you know
they would write it on there yeah yeah
that was huge like three points would
you tell a narc was it pretty obvious
they were just like when they weren't in
camo or whatever the [ __ ] they're
wearing cargo shorts in our town it was
easy to tell narcs because the police
were just it was small they're too nice
to him well and the guy would always
that we'd be like what town are you from
and he would be like oh i'm from just
like right over it right over here right
over the creek
yeah anybody there's no creep towns
around you know creeks around here bro
you just spill an icelandic water all
right just pick a town bro you couldn't
even name a town and i remember some of
the narcs would be like this 35 oh they
had like this one he was like 35 years
old and he came back as an arc and he
had real smooth skin and he was like
kind of uh
i don't know yeah that's big dark energy
if you got smooth skin selling drugs no
zits and you're selling drugs that
doesn't check out
and he would just yeah he would like he
kept saying uh that he was from texas or
something you know some place that like
people like knew about but then it
really had never been
and then i remember he started dating a
girl at our school
and then they busted him for being a
pervert
and he was supposed to be busting us
damn it be your own narcs you know
married that girl lauren actually which
is crazy he went to jail i think and
then got out and then married her for
pedophilia
i mean i think he went for
you know indecency with a minors i think
a lot of why was it always history
teachers that were the closest to
pedophiles our history teacher he would
knock girls pencils off the desk so he'd
check out the rack when he dropped it
now that's not to give anybody ideas but
he would like like if you were like oh
uh what what's what's the answer you
knock off the pencil so you'd like reach
down and he would just stare at the
grand tetons stare at them nugs
them young nuggets and he did that for a
couple years real thick glasses
17 year old tits would you look at them
[Laughter]
seems like you're a narc right now dude
where's his feet going huh where's his
feet going nashville pd
is just a straight is that a producer is
he a narc
yeah i mean that's a crazy question
is it that crazy
yeah but this guy dude he came back to
our school yeah and he's like his first
thing was like who's he who's selling
drugs or like what that's what i'm
saying the questions they ask are crazy
who's trying to do the weed the
the who wants to smoke meth out of a
spork dog gets a spoon [ __ ] act right
dude narcs are always the dude and it
was always some kid usually that had
been in school for so long and couldn't
graduate school he dropped out and now
so like he fake dropped out but he still
went to class under like an alias you
know you back with like a different name
yeah yeah you're like this dude couldn't
spell his first name yeah his original
name is now he's lance and narc's never
had plans what are you guys doing
tonight it's like you just know what
you're doing on a friday in high school
you know but if you have to ask for
plans narc narcs never had plans they
got like a face tattoo that's just a
henna teardrop and you're like is that
is that a henna he's like i got this
[ __ ] blasted last night dog
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one